bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenute
questo nuovo video io sono cat mario e
oggi andrò a rompere il cazzo per la 545
millesima volta a vari j
grazie stronzo ragazzi siamo su cat
mario 3 perché sta tenendo il microfono
sto già impazzendo dalla strada e fatemi
posare tutto qua che c'è un carro armato
in mano bene non avrei mai pensato di
poterlo dire ma ci hanno fatto un 3d sta
merda ragazzi cioè impossibile allora la
prima parte la dovrei sapere perché l'ho
fatta nello speciale
non lo so allora prima parte e dovrebbe
essere ok ho scattato qualcosa subito
non me ne frega niente no no bene allora
la prima parte in teoria 3 o di odio
odio a fare il deficente non c'è mai
limite ragazzi perfetto vediamo di
riuscirci no io non si possono vedere
allora hanno fatto un 3d sta merda io
l'ho anche giocata porca [ __ ] allora
veniamo di riuscirci non è imposto
ucciso salito qui sopra non si dovesse
salire ma sarò a devo prendere non apre
la nuvola porca [ __ ] [ __ ] olè olè
olè olè olè ragazzi cos'è poi muoio
sicura l'alternativa è così
mamma mia due killer ha dalla sua parte
la sorte allora il primo cubo ok
perfetto grandi allora questo da adesso
in avanti non so più una mazza dopo devo
scendere pian piano
devo certo non devo scendere
perfetto salto della fede non ci sono
riuscito permetta una grande suk andare
avanti però vado a caso spero di
riuscire a beccare qualcosa ok calmi
calmi
beh vabbè allora le monete non le prendo
vado avanti così
[Musica]
io non le volevo prendere le monete ma
sto stronzo di merda fa di testa sua
piano piano piazze ok ragazza nuvola è
stronzo lo so già perfetto ok ci sono
riuscito bene allora non so dove devo
andare adesso parlo io salto a caso
spero di non beccare nulla allora piano
piano che ci sto riuscendo dove la prima
bandiera raga di preciso non lo so ok io
io io so già che sia potuta di nomi
incazzare no che culo
ok gli otto proseguire la caccia sto
facendo da fermi un attimo
ok io questo l'ho far fuori si no no non
stavo per cadere
ok ragazzi sono devo riuscire a capire
come cazzo fare sta parte fermi a borca
punta adesso mi spiegate perchè la
tartaruga si è fermata a mezz'aria non è
possibile
[Musica]
vabbè che poi non è capito su un casco
non me ne frega la minchia
piuttosto non so fammi morire un'altra
volta ti faccio fare un volo dal quarto
piano all'altro da un attimo madonna ok
alla ragazzi devo beccare qualcosa lì
penso sia il primo perché non vedo altre
soluzioni se faccio così non c'è niente
per te
ci sia qualcosa di quando veca nel primo
il primo ok calmi
adesso adesso la cosa si fa complicata
dalla spettacolo saltiamo così che sia
ben si era formata da un musica mi sono
caricato addosso allora calmi cosa sto
facendo ragazzi ci siamo ma non ho
capito che si basta parte non lo so
[Musica]
frutto di merda
allora ragazzi vedevo lì dominare come
si deve iniziamo da dio allora vediamo
di riuscirci st parte mi sembra più
incazzata di quelli prima vai cos'è vai
così voi così più incazzata nel senso
che io mi incazzo aironi più e penso di
avere anche ragione ma non importa noi
facciamo
proviamoci guarda terminò giorni nel
santissimo com'è possibile finisco
sempre bene ragazzi
ok sto scrivendo tutto alla matrix non
so cotti no proprio tutto perché le
nuvole invisibili permette non hanno in
mente che c'erano proprio però vabbè
ragazzi ce la posso fare fermi fermi che
qua ci sono ok e attraverso gruppo li va
a fan culo
perché se crollano i pavimenti perché a
raga questa e quella buonanno sentono se
lo faccio tutto lo finisco da d'avino
avanti fisco che mario senza morire lo
so me lo sento vai così facciamo dalla
prossima bene bene bene bene bene
olè olè olè olè un cazzo le raga mi si
stanno triturando i maroni come faccio a
questa parte ci aiuta c'è tipo tipo che
mario 2 che puoi saltare nove erano poi
puoi saltare no perché non pensando a
livelli poco perché che mario non salta
come cazzo si fa allora termico lo farà
giustizia che tu sei cool assurdo non ci
posso credere federati un po pazzo di
sopra perché mi sento figo uscente
obbligo e posto di sopra di 82 morti c'è
massimo a ragazzi imposti dalla fermi
questo sai dove dopo i mettere lo sai
dove te lo puoi mettere lo sai
porca [ __ ] ad ora come faccio a far
la parte che impossibile il giallo già
lo so che crolla qualcosa
ok ragazzi
non c'è una [ __ ] bandiera è trovata
driver c'è la bandiera allora presentati
avuto raggiunto la bandiera vipre cos'è
sta roba
[Musica]
ragazzi forse mi devo far prendere da
questi ci voglio credere
non ci voglio credere non ci credo ok
ragazzi siamo capito come si fa bene
allora in qua ci siamo e gioca come
faccio a far le altre parti allora qua
ci sono i cosi va bene la facciamo così
brutto stronzo
ok il raggio più piano già facciamo da
fermi fermi se lei avevo il cadere
dritto dove cadere dritto
[Musica]
non ci credo conti strano anzi non mi
avrete fare un caricatore di mitra nel
dietro brutto stronzo se come faccio fa
l'esame
ragazzi io non ci volevo cercare hackett
mario 3 me l'avete avevo messo cinque
opzioni 5.000 avete votati 1430 per fare
perché perché che tu mario tutto mi
volete bene porca [ __ ] lo sapete solo
poi non è possibile che faccio si no se
ma vi rendete conto con 115 morti 115
morta vittima 16 ragazze nhtsa guardare
o mio dio mio dio cosa ho fatto
[Musica]
raga io sto impazzendo perché mi fatto
giocate facciamo così però guardare in
camera e giocare una cosa impossibile
cioè ci sto non ci sto vedendo un
pochettino non ha poco poco
ragazza mi sta salendo un esaurimento
nervoso che probabilmente già salito da
un pezzo
basta ci prova l'ultima volta dai vai
direi di concludere qui prima che la
situazione si faccia molto brutta evito
è piaciuto dunque lasciato il commento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook che
come in ogni video trovate nella
descrizione se non siete ancora iscritti
iscrivetevi ci vediamo non fossimo vito
belle ragazze